dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with dr carol jonaife i cannot
tell you how excited i am by this paper
wow today you will see more incredible
images generated by google's newest ai
called party yes this is not from open
ai
but from google so
what is going on here just a few months
ago openai's image generator ai called
dolly 2 took the world by storm with
that you could name almost anything cat
napoleon a teddy bear on a skateboard on
times square a basketball player dunking
as an explosion of a nebula
and it was able to create an appropriate
image for it it is also good enough to
be used in our own thumbnails
however there was one interesting thing
about it what do you think the prompt
for this must have been
not easy right well it was a sign that
says deep learning
oh yes this was one of the failure cases
please remember this
now we always say that in research do
not look at where we are always look at
where we will be two more papers down
the line that is the first law of papers
however we didn't even make it to two
more papers down the line what's more we
barely made two months down the line and
scientists at google came up with an
amazing follow-up paper it was called
imogen
imogen was absolutely incredible as it
could now finally synthesize text
properly it could also understand when
we say a couple of glasses on a table
and one this little linguistic battle
against open ai's dolly too
and all this just two months after it
that is absolutely amazing but hold on
to your papers because you won't believe
this one i certainly didn't when i saw
it first just about one month after
imogen here is an even newer paper on ai
image generation called party
that is fantastic welcome to our world
little ai matt why does this exist
well this is why i'll explain in a
moment but first let's have a look at
what it can do through three of my
favorite examples and then we'll discuss
why it exists one let's start with the
banger and recreate the legendary
napoleon cat with the new method
this is dolly 2 solution
and let's see the new one
i cannot believe it this is at least as
good as dolly two's legendary solution
and i have to say
maybe even a touch better
what a time to be alive
two a crocodile made of water
as someone who has spent some time
researching controlling fluid and smoke
simulations this one is highly
appreciated
three a detailed athenian vase with
egyptian hieroglyphics
and more
i love how party was able to bring all
of these concepts together into one
coherent solution
this may be subjective but if someone
told me that a person made this i would
say that person is quite creative
but creativity in a machine
how cool is that
now remember this image i said that this
is why party exists so what is going on
here well look the two previous
techniques used a diffusion based model
this means that when we ask it something
it starts out from noise and over time
it learns to organize these pixels to
form a beautiful image that matches our
description better
now look
aha
this party technique is not a diffusion
diffusion-based model it is an
autoregressive model
what does that mean it means that it
uses no diffusion it does not create a
piece of noise and refine it into an
image
no sir instead it thinks of an image as
a collection of little puzzle pieces
why
well this hopefully helps with two other
shortcomings of dolly 2 one is
generating a specific number of objects
that did not work too well before
and it can also deal with super long
prompts
much longer than previous ones you got
me excited now you know what let's test
that right now together let's add this
prompt
oh my goodness now that is a long prompt
who can paint this
almost nobody in fact it is the
description of van gogh's starry night
without saying that we are looking for
starry night i am itching to see this
and
oh wow
all of them are lovely
now we have two more really spectacular
things about this paper
one we can witness how it learns to draw
these beautiful images as we increase
the model size which roughly tells us
how capable the ai is we can take a
smaller model and ask it to create a
kangaroo with sunglasses and a sign that
says hello friends and we get
this
well that is a start it can't really
write yet and the details are lacking
but when we use the same architecture
with the difference that we increase the
model size to be about 50 times bigger
we get this
oh my goodness it not only learned to
write but the quality of the output is
also leaps and bounds better
what do you think what results would
another 50-fold increase result in
that must be something truly incredible
let me know in the comments below
alongside the paper scientists at google
also released a bunch of prompts as a
benchmark for testing future image
generator ais
and yes there are some good ones in
there but if i may make some
recommendations i would love to see
some of these prompts of mine in such a
benchmark
for instance the fox scientists the
scholars and the cyber frog are very
well received by you fellow scholars and
it would be super cool to be able to
compare how new more elaborate ai models
are able to deal with these i also put a
text version of these in the video
description if someone is interested
so it's official the age of beautiful ai
generated images is now here does this
get your mind going what do you think
let me know in the comments below if
you're looking for inexpensive cloud
gpus for ai lambda now offers the best
prices in the world for gpu cloud
compute no commitments or negotiation
required just sign up and launch an
instance and hold on to your papers
because with lambda gpu cloud you can
get on-demand a100 instances for 1.10
per hour versus 4.10 per hour with aws
that's 73 percent savings did i mention
they also offer persistent storage so
join researchers at organizations like
apple
mit and caltech in using lambda cloud
instances workstations or servers make
sure to go to lambdalabs.com
papers to sign up for one of their
amazing gpu instances today thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and i'll see you next time